if I said to you 10 P 3 by the way I
would just say sometimes this is colored
queerly
red as 10 pick 3 versus 10 choose 3 I
get it but I don't really like it
because what's the difference between
choosing and picking whereas there is a
difference between a permutation and a
combination automatic you're arranging
things and here what it doesn't matter
you just putting him in a heap okay so
you make you people say that but that's
why I don't say it 10 P 3 how would you
explain it's the number of ways to what
okay yes so you've got 10 to choose from
10 article 10 options right so this is
the number of ways to arrange 3 objects
when you've got 10 that you could choose
from right right that's fine okay now 10
P 10 just following the pattern is the
way to arrange 10 objects with 10
options then you might recall this was a
special can you remind me based on the
definition of what NPK is what is 10 P 3
in the numbers not the final number how
do you work out okay so it ends up being
synthetic yeah all right on 10 P 10 now
because as um as is just mentioned this
is 10 take away 3 that's how you get 7
right so what's this okay so by the way
like when you were first learn what
factorial notation is people say oh zero
factorial that doesn't make sense though
because 2 is 2 times 1 3 is 3 times 2
etcetera so what's this like you're not
there to get too mad right now there's a
fancy argument for why this is the case
of show to you then if you're curious
but one of the really obvious reason is
why it must be the case is actually
precisely
sense of this notation it has to be this
way this must be one otherwise
everything just pretty I think no so the
picture afflictions a computer you know
yeah
Oh argue for a lady if you like but if
something else I want to point out
before I get to that
so under funny 0 factorial is 1 so
that's a 10 factorial right and you know
this is actually kind of how we started
right if you got a bunch of objects and
you want to arrange all of them then we
pictured having n boxes right do you
remember this and you're like or 10 9 8
all the way down to one that's 10
factorial right so this is just a
special case of NPK right just it's ed
Pete does that make sense okay good stay
with me follow the pattern now I'm now
changing into 10 C 3 so what's the
difference between this guy and this guy
how would i phrase this to my yeah
that's the only difference
yeah so a range versus choose means
order versus don't wanna okay so I want
to choose three objects instead of
arrange them and I still have the
original two options okay now I look
like this another connection to binomial
theorem because the original connection
I gave you was if you take something
like a plus B of binomial and you raise
it to a power like three okay the reason
why the coefficients end up being these
guys is because when you expand this
right what the expression is like at the
end I guess you have a cubed plus three
this plus
this plus okay so what this means is
there are three ways to get two A's in a
bit there are three ways to get an AM to
B's right so you're choosing from here
and because you've collapsed them all
together you don't care about the order
anymore that's why it's this guy okay so
now I want you to help me remember we
have let a bunch of identities to do
with this binomial coefficient right in
particular because these guys we first
met the actual numbers from Pascal's
triangle we learned that if you count it
up from zero one two and three okay this
is the like increases zero term it's a
form on a wall ring this is equal from
the other end to what okay I think I can
encourage the numbers because of course
if this is what our definition of 10 p3
is right you start with this but that
you realize away I have over counter do
you remember why have I ever counted
from here to here yeah that's right it's
like you know those three that you
picked you can arrange them in three
factorial ways and all of those ways
look the same to you if you don't care
about the order
it's that make sense and you can see why
this is going to give you this do you
see you're just going to do the 3
factorial first and then the same
venture same deal now I want to ask you
why because that's what the numbers tell
you but what what interpretation makes
sense is okay so here my own here my 10
objects that I'm choosing from again now
if I were to choose 3 so I want to give
me three colors blue pink and I think
minsu said red okay there you go whoops
it's a bit
alright now I've picked a pick three
okay and the number of ways to do that
is considerable okay so I can work out
what that is
I've picked three and I'm suggesting but
the number of ways there is to pick
three is the same as the way the number
of ways to pick seven now that seems a
bit posh attention sir seems a bit weird
to me you shouldn't there be so many
more ways of choosing these guys because
there's so many of them right okay so
here's the connection right and maybe
it's sort of like flu plots are quite
quickly to choose three objects from ten
options right those three up there right
is exactly the same you can in fact see
it here to do brights right
choosing three is the same as choosing
seven to not have in your group I
suppose you want to pick your captor
vice-captain or whatever okay you've got
your your trifecta your three up there
which is the same as saying which ones
you're going to reject okay so in fact
he can be choosing rather these three
and choosing these seven is exactly the
same problem that's why they have the
same answer okay now this is kind of
like thinking about a compliment but in
terms of counting rather than
probability okay so these kinds of
comments are actually equal to each
other we say there's a one-to-one
correspondence between these write the
number of ways I can pick three if you
pick all of the different clients like
that one and then that one and then that
one you can see each of these
combinations of three corresponds to
exactly one combination of seven and
there's that's why it is exactly the
same number of each you